[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're going to be talking about
our first memory and in general the
nature of first memory yes so yeah what
we'll take a trip down all the way to
the beginning of memory lane again let
me just say that you listening and maybe
us talking
it isn't unlikely that your first memory
didn't even happen so disappointed I
know I know my first memory happened
there's no doubt what a lot of people
think that it's just because it's so
real to me and I've you know I had an
interesting conversation with my kids
about this that led to a app realization
practice that I think can be applied to
any well any parent or mentor or so if
you have influence on a on a certain
type of person sinister but you know I
we should acknowledge and I want to
acknowledge the the last four weeks and
our lost year's series now full
disclosure we're recording this just a
few days before my episode which is part
4 comes out so as we're recording this
we don't really have the benefit of
experience in the response to my episode
so I'm still anxiously awaiting to
medicated it but I do
that's your prediction but I do think
that but I mean yours has been out we've
been processing that we've been talking
about it well I
a lot of people are you using hashtag
you're busy I mean I think that we've
gotten I think is very safe to say that
we've gotten more engagement and
reaction to this series this so so far
even without your episode your episodes
only gonna help just there's a
conversation that's happening there's
lots of questions thoughts that are
being put out there and we have every
intention to continue the conversation
so I think that
you know us talking about our spiritual
background and where we're at now and we
this is now a part of ear biscuits in
general and so we're going to return to
that conversation so that it's not just
this hey we talked about it and we're
never talking about it again so we're
gonna we'll use your questions and
comments kind of as a springboard to get
us back into that conversation but that
won't be the end of it either and we
can't I don't know exactly when we're
gonna do that it won't necessarily be
next week but yeah I'll say it's it'll
be sooner versus later I didn't you know
we do want to continue that conversation
while so many of you are we just have to
process my episode and then you know
gather up everything that you've you've
said using hash tag your biscuits which
we've been doing so yeah there's still
time for you to submit questions or your
responses and it's kind of a new
experience to have this level of a
conversation going on around the show I
mean the fact that I think the first
reason that we did it is was for
ourselves and even even without my
episode not being out yet I can honestly
say that it was crying across the big
threshold of me even just recording it
and I know sorry it was very meaningful
to just for us to put this out there for
ourselves and just to know that it that
it resonates with with so many people
and/or it conflicts with some people
even you know and it creates that that
dialogue and a conversation I just think
we're honored to have a community of
listeners that are the vast majority is
it's it's cordial it's it's the there's
a it's loving it's positive and I will
say yeah I I definitely and I tweeted
that out as a result of just the initial
reaction that I got to my story the vast
majority of people regardless of where
they're at you know spiritually whether
that's you know more similar to
what we used to be or more similar to
what we are now everyone has been mostly
everyone has been like really civil
simply and respectful and kind and kind
and understanding and I think that that
is again we didn't talk about this to
create some sort of division I
understand that anytime you talk about
religion or politics
you are just stepping right into it
especially just sort of the climate of
our country right now you're asking
people to fight and thankfully that
really hasn't happened it happened a
little bit but we just want to say that
this is not about creating an
us-versus-them in-group and out-group
kind of thing we just want to have a
dialogue we're just we're trying to have
an honest dialogue and and thank you for
being a part of that but let's just
remember to keep it cordial keep it
curious and respectful respectful and
we'll keep the conversation going
I also thought it was cool that the
number of conversations that we're
having with like our our friends from
college you know where we're now having
an ongoing conversation with them about
all this because I mean they shared so
many of those experiences with us and
like if you listened to our conversation
about digital relationships or
conducting friendships over text that
was instrumental in us reconnecting with
those friends and now it it's a really
rewarding conversation that we're having
with them over this topic and there's
people coming out of the woodwork who we
haven't heard from in years who were
saying that they're listening it turns
out being on The Tonight Show it doesn't
do it it's just talking about your
background that's what that's where you
get all the phone calls and texts and
you know what there's also a number of
people who I think their introduction to
us has been this series based on simply
looking at the numbers I mean yeah
there's people who are listening I guess
right now that weren't listening five
episodes ago so welcome
welcome to ear biscuits if if you if the
your first introduction to this podcast
or us was the series we just want to say
welcome welcome to the herd of mythical
beasts that's what we call ourselves we
invite you to stick around and listen to
this podcast every week or if you want
to watch it you can watch it on YouTube
the following what is it Saturday Sunday
and what well let's talk a little bit
about what the what the podcast is I
mean I think it's also just a moment to
kind of recognize for all of you who've
been listening for a a long period of
time I think you've seen an evolution in
this and this show from you know talking
to interviewing youtubers years ago to
doing just a bunch of miscellaneous
stuff to kind of settling into this
place where it's just two guys who grew
up together who now work together who
are still best friends just doing life
together and processing it and talking
about it sometimes it's personal and I
think that's how we got to telling our
stories is that we had told you so many
things about our past and our experience
and the way that we see things and we
had never gotten into that specific sort
of giant part of who we were so it just
sort of there was just a lot of critical
mass building towards this hey let's
just let you guys in on this part of
ourselves but it's really because the
nature of the show that's what it's
become it's become a very personal sort
of processing yeah I mean it's it it's a
big part of us conducting our friendship
you know and also like just reporting
and processing everything that's going
on are alive so is this podcast just
gonna be about our spiritual
perspectives moving forward no but it is
I think now that we've you know we've
unearthed it that it you know much more
readily be a part of the conversation on
any given week which I we were starting
to feel that tension that there were
certain things that we could we could
speak about but that we
weren't quite there yet so I do think it
the lost year series will impacts the
overall complexion and that I won't say
the tone but like this the subject
matters of what we're going to talk
about but hey basically we're just here
to hang out with each other and hang out
with you so keep doing it and keep
coming back we'll still be here sounds
like the end of the podcast is that it
alright see you next week nope no no no
no no we haven't even done anything yet
and so sometimes we talk about things
that are just interesting to us but we
usually try to find a personal
connection and that's why we're talking
about the nature of your earliest
memories oh we should also say if you
really don't have a point of reference
we have to keep plugging we have five
videos a week on a show called good
mythical morning and every day there's a
good mythical more episode you can watch
that too every Saturday we do a vlog
where it's it's sometimes it's like a
video version of ear biscuits in terms
of a lot of the stories that will tell I
think a lot of those were capturing for
for our Saturday release on our
rhettandlink channel so check that out
if you haven't checked out our vlogs
youtube.com slash rhett and Link is that
enough of the plugs or should we just go
full in with like ads we should just go
straight to an ad you can get full plot
full plug right here okay look at that
full plug plug plug into this t-shirt
you can get links t-shirt not the jacket
but the t-shirt at mythical calm and
it's not the only thing that can you can
get there there's lots of other things
other t-shirts long-sleeve shirts
hoodies pins notebooks beard oil lip
balm palmate the list goes on I mean
it's well look isn't gonna go on but it
could go to mythical calm wrap your boys
BAM okay so we're gonna share like and
we we have done this at some point
totally my ending but I don't know we
probably mentioned what our first
memories are but I don't remember what
yours is
I don't matter what yours is already
forgot you guys first memory so that'll
be fun you sure you're met you should
remember your friend's first memories I
think that they they don't mean as much
to someone else if they're to remember
them as if you as you remembering them
yourself and I don't know maybe well
impact it there's when we when we go
through the specifics of our memories
that there is more meaning in it than we
even realized and it's funny because the
other night I was tucking I was tucking
lando in the bed he's 9 years old and
that's when we get some good quality
time he has this like hammock seat
hammock chair thing hanging beside his
bed sometimes I'll sit in that and just
dangle and we'll just have a little
conversation that's odd word to use and
it was there and I don't know what
prompted this conversation but I was
like I know what's the first thing you
remember I was just curious at his age
and we got into talking about that and
Lant we landed in a place that where I
feel like I got a big idea you land out
in a place I land out on a big idea so
we can get back to what his memory is or
whatever but where do you want to stow
that's what you felt like you were gonna
tell us no I'm just saying that's kind
of why I wanted to talk about this
you're not here to disclose his first
memory I can't well he's like I said
he's 9 years old
and when we moved to Los Angeles he was
he was one you know so I was like how
long did we stay in that first apartment
we only stayed there six months there's
no way you remembers that I'm like and I
was like Lando you don't remember living
in an apartment in Los Angeles right he
was like no I was like yeah you were in
a crib there's no way you could remember
that and like I was like nin our we had
this house after that where we moved and
we stayed there for three years and I
started to describe the place I was like
there was it it the driveway was blue do
you remember that he was like no I was
like there was a there was a hammock in
the backyard remember that hammock that
we got
from like Cotulla x' was a sponsor and
it was like this weird like
self-supporting hammock he definitely
remember green this place and I was like
do you remember that and he was like no
and I like called Lincoln in there like
am I crazy do you remember this I was
like you remember all this you remember
you mean in Encino yeah in Encino when I
lived there and then I started
describing the inside of the house and
he was like hold on I remember I
remember my bunk bed because out do we
have bunk beds I was like yes and he was
like and I was on the bottom because I
remember I would have to reach up and
grab and hang stuff from the slats but I
had to force my hand in there because
Lincoln was laying on the mattress I was
like there you go do you remember our
purple couches he's like no mestia he's
not gonna remember not gonna remember
that that's like and then Lincoln came
in there and he was like do you remember
that neighbor who you go over to his
house and play and he had that he had a
dog who was deaf and Landon was like
yeah we'll call him all the time and he
would never respond because he was deaf
yeah he couldn't hear and it was like
and he had a rabbit and when they would
go out of town he was like yeah we'd go
over there and we feed the rabbit and
they had a trampoline and that and that
is what we determined is his first
memory a rabbit on a trampoline a deaf
dog a rabbit and a trampoline Wow
three totally sounds like an Adult Swim
show yeah yeah yeah if you can find
those three things you did for a good
well it's interesting that the way that
you got him to remember that because
that's kind of that's one of the one of
the Articles that I read from psych
central.com entitled what's your
earliest memory from August 2018 by
Janice wood good all right last name so
there's these guys at Emory University
would you like to remember your first
researchers at Emory University so I'm
just gonna quote some of this few adults
can remember anything that happened to
them before the age of three now a new
study has documented that it's about age
7 when our earliest memories begin to
fade a phenomenon known as childhood
amnesia
so you don't know so everything up until
everything from four years old to seven
years old you remember and then after
seven you start to lose stuff I would
say three to seven because in this other
article and and this is very pertinent
because so many people think that they
remember things interestingly my first
memory comes from age three that's early
which is they say that's about the
earliest that you can do it let me see
what does it say okay about four out of
every ten people have fabricated their
first memory according to researchers
this is another article at BBC the BBC
sitcom called can you trust your
earliest childhood memories but
basically okay they examine the first
memories of six thousand six hundred and
forty-one people and the scientists
found that two thousand four hundred
eighty seven of the memory shared such
as sitting in a prom I don't know I'm
not familiar with English terms sitting
in a prom yeah the PRA M Oh a pram for
pram so like is like some kind of like I
don't know what there's some vehicle or
something okay care about a bassinet or
like a stroller yeah yeah yeah so 2004
987 memories which is almost half were
from before the participants had reached
the age to age of two with 14% of
participants claiming to remember an
event before their first birthday and
some even before their own birth oh gosh
but the fact is people people trying to
be overachievers it's like you saying
your first memories when you're three
because you know that scientifically the
earliest you can so you're trying to
achieve these people don't know the
science and they're lying to it
basically just says that your brain is
not capable it doesn't have the
structures that it needs - yeah form the
kinds of things that you would carry on
and you may
well I was special and I remember being
there are people who think they remember
being in their mother's womb or they
think they remember their own birth and
then a lot of people think in fact Freud
taught this that you do have all those
old memories but you've suppressed them
friendless and Freud he all he did was
grasp at straws and make stuff up man
but there's a good by the way I know
nothing about him except hey
he makes stuff up okay here you go so
young children tend to forget events
where reveling in it
now I will say newborns do have memories
of being in the womb they will respond
they will respond to things on the
outside based on what they heard on the
inside like somehow science does no no
I'm not saying but but you don't then
have the ability to retain or the Tainos
memories and bring him into adulthood
she says this this one researcher says
memories are like orzo which is a pasta
referring to the rice grain size pasta
little bits and pieces of neural
encoding young children's brains are
like calendars with large holes trying
to retain these little pieces of memory
as the water rushes out so do many of
the grains of orzo adults however use a
fine net instead of a colander for a
screen then you get to be our age and
that net gets a bunch of holes in it
so basically oh so but the childhood
amnesia thing is this the idea that
you've got these memories that you
remember from about age three and then
once you turn seven on average you begin
to lose those memories unless you've got
some mechanisms to continue to remember
them right yeah and a lot of times that
can be a picture or video yeah I think a
lot of people are just there first
they're remembering something they
projected on a picture that they've
looked at in a photo album for years
afterward what's well yeah because a lot
of times you're constructing many people
had a photo from inside of a womb I've
got lots of those I've got a whole
folder okay freak it's just called don't
I don't want to know whatever else I
don't
oh right is that what's gone No
you get sonogram what do you get when
you go to sonogram sonogram yeah that's
not what I try to remember all I try to
[ __ ] about is if a baby took a
Polaroid from the inside that's what
they're doing now you pass in a Polaroid
not and then the baby gets the picture
yeah exactly
well that's not what happens and I don't
even know how we got on this it's not
very pertinent because it's people use
people will see a picture from a point
in their past and then they will
construct a memory around it that's what
happens a lot of times there's all kinds
of ways to implant false memories but I
don't want to go too much more into it
because I want to talk about what are we
resorbed but essentially if you think
you remember something before the age of
three
you probably don't if you if you think
you remember it before the age of two
like when you were like 1 or younger you
definitely don't remember it and you
need to come up with a new memory and
you know what we still accept you you
know what you don't have to you don't
have to remember stuff from way back
then for us to love you I love you I
love you if you don't remember anything
you know dang what's your first memory I
was three it was Halloween which means I
had just turned 3 oh she's pretty
unusual but you know I'm one of those
guys maybe you had just turned 4 no cuz
it was in Georgia okay I have to talk to
my mom maybe I turned but he was in
Georgia and I think I turned four in
California when we moved at Thousand
Oaks
maybe I just turned four but I think I
just turned three but this is my
earliest memory Halloween I had decided
to be Big Bird for reasons that should
be obvious I'm big I like birds do you
remember being hypersensitive to being
the tallest kid at that age of course
that that might have been your first
memory so I don't know kindergarten no
I've never I've never had a sense of
being like a real a real sense of being
that much bigger and taller than people
until
people keep telling me that I am right
so I don't think I was very
self-conscious about it even though you
look at the pictures you know how did
they why did they let this eighth grader
into this preschool class you know is he
that is he a teacher's assistant it
looks a little young for that
I guess choosing Big Bird does reflect
like it's certain either confidence or
at least an ambivalence to to your
height but I mean Big Bird stalls so
feels like I know I'm tall and that's
this will work well let's be clear here
if I was three years old I did not
select a Big Bird big bird was selected
for me oh this is your parents shaming
which this is might might need to be
something that I explore in therapy is
that that's right my mom most likely and
my dad's not picking out Halloween
costumes I know he is my mom decided for
me that I should be Big Bird mm-hmm
now I remember being very excited about
being Big Bird so maybe I your first
memory being excited no I'm gonna tell
you the first memory I'm the dog it just
only the story only makes sense in light
of me actually being excited about being
big bird because I wanted to go
trick-or-treating I was excited to go
trick-or-treating I was gonna get to go
with my brother who was three years
older than me was he Wiley coyote I
don't even remember what he was because
this isn't his memory it's mine you
didn't even care huh I feel like he
might have been a robot but I honestly
don't remember I was Wiley coyote one
year and I'm not even lying and it might
have been the same time I'll have to I
know there's a picture of me as Wiley
coyote and I've never realized this
until this moment but why like already
is like a Warner Brothers character oh
shoot I'm getting big bird you're are
you confusing the Sesame Street universe
I'm getting Big Bird loony with the
roadrunner hey man that would have been
a good corner hold on you were the
roadrunner I was Wiley coyote oh okay
and you were the roadrunner I would've
met you right but I was I was Big Bird I
screwed it up man I thought that would
have been serendipity back to your story
and of course this was 1980 probably
which meant that my costume consisted of
like
like some sort of vinyl you know what I
mean plastic it was very plastic and if
you recall it's like a plastic tarp with
a hold that your head goes through even
in a mask if you recall your memory of
big bird you might not remember his legs
remember the color of his legs orange
legs with pink rings yeah I would just I
would have just said it was orange and
pink striped legs like horizontal
stripes that go up the leg pink and
orange yeah and that's what I remember
I'm not gonna bring up a picture of a
big bird too because I want this to be a
pristine thing in my in my mind okay and
literally the first step out the door I
tripped on something fell down and fell
on my knee and ripped a hole in the
vinyl and also it's kind of skin ting my
knee up and at that point it was that
I'm embarrassed because my whole my
costume has a hole in it yeah I think
you knew if people looked at your knee
they would know there's a human there
like that's not Big Bird I can see a
human knee under there yeah so the whole
plan and to fall apart and I just stayed
in what I remember again this I don't
know what part is constructed and what
part actually happened I remember
staying inside and they had to like
bring I you know like my brother would
bring me some of his candy like I had to
use some of his candy because I didn't
actually go out though so you just
stayed you stayed back with your dad
probably your mom took your brother out
don't remember those details I told you
everything that I remember okay so
that's your first memory there's a
little trauma there may be a lot of
trauma seems like a lot I'd be
interested in what your parents say
about this when I keep when I was
walking across a parking lot this
morning you were sitting in your car on
the phone I thought you I thought I
heard to do it your mom's voice you did
you're talking to your mom in the car
you should have asked her about this
I didn't she's I don't remember you tell
me something else what else is there to
talk about my dad called me last night
this is a side note yeah I I mailed him
a felony I mailed him lost calls oblique
reek
finally and I also gave him one of our
records you know mythical Society when
we covered Merle and it come you know it
comes with that sticker in it that says
mythical recording and my dad was
talking about the record he said he
liked the album cover and all that stuff
and how if you turn it over it's the
reverse and and then he said and now you
know that little thing that says
mythical recording on it if if I were to
if I were to peel that off would that
would I be it would that stick on
something what would that mess it up and
I was like yeah it's fine that it's it's
a sticker haha it is a sticker I think
that's the word you're looking for he's
like wow I knew what a sticker was I
just didn't know if this was a sticker
there's only you had a much more
interesting conversation that I deal
with mom we didn't talk about stickers
at all well so do you want to hear my
first memory and then we'll analyze both
of them um my first memory was let's see
before I went to preschool so I went to
preschool when I was like six and then
were five no I went to kindergarten I
was six preschool when I was like five
so from the age like two to four I
stayed at read errs house Loretta you
met her she's my first babysitter she
only kept me and my first best friend
Brad that I talk about in the book of
mythicality
and so my first memories are at her
house where I would spend the day I
remember one day we would always stay at
her house we would rarely leave and
maybe that's why I remember this because
it was very unusual because we did leave
we went to a friend of hers house and it
was it it was maybe a mile or two away
still away in the country and there was
this she we we were playing in the
backyard there were some other kids
there I remember being very afraid of
other kids like even in preschool I
don't know I liked the people that I
knew man
and um but I was what were you afraid of
I don't know what was gonna happen I
don't know just the people miss of them
I don't know I haven't gotten into that
but I do remember I was in the backyard
and I was on the swing set thing and you
know they got like normal swings but in
there like metal swings but you've got
this certain type of swing that it's got
two benches that face each other and
then so and as it swings it kind of
stays parallel you don't tell me like a
very old-timey type swing but it's two
people facing each other on this thing
you never been on one of those and you
stay too tall you stay in the same the
same height you stay parallel to the
ground but you move up and down because
it's kind of like a rowboat kind of vibe
I don't know it's kind of there's - I
think you're making this up there's even
a swing two bars there's two bars that
come down one in front of one person and
one in front of the one beside the other
person oh and you got on a chain you
know it's on bars and it's they're fixed
and you're facing the other person I was
on it by myself and I was holding on to
the bars and I'm racing no one it like
I'm pretty sure it pinched or the way I
would have said it at the time was it
pinched me it pinched my hand and cut it
and there was blood and my recollection
is it but there was a lot of blood and I
remember running into this strangers
house and trying to find redder and well
first of all before you continue I will
say that they don't make jungle gym
equipment like they used to
oh no I actually believe everything is
so safe now I think that there should be
like a way that a kid could come away
from a piece of equipment bleeding just
as a life lesson maybe one less ear yeah
I mean I think that every piece of
playground equipment that is
manufactured now should have like one
really unnecessarily sharp point you
know like a jagged edge so that at least
once a year one kid really gets snagged
on that thing and then the custodia
should come out with a paintbrush of
tetanus and just kind of like brush it
well tennis is probably overkill but I
think you gotta have some blood and some
scars what else you gonna remember as
we're demonstrating here so I run into
redder and I love I love this woman
she's she's very short I I think I'm I I
bond with people who are of extreme
Heights
my wife's pretty tall for her height for
her height for her age I don't know what
I was gonna say pretty tall for your
height baby for her sex okay did you say
pretty tall for a woman okay yeah yeah
she's woman that's beside the point
Loretta's way sometimes she's like
sometimes the way out for ten there's a
lot easier than human
Loretta's like for ten she was like the
most approachable person to a kid and
she made me feel better that was that's
my that's my first memory did she kiss
it I don't think she kiss your booty she
cleaned it up she cleaned up the boo-boo
and I don't remember Brad being there
but I remember my second memory and
again it may have come first I really
have no way to know was the one I tell
in the book of mythicality and that's I
go into the bathroom right after he came
out of the bathroom and he forgot to
flush and there was a turd in there that
was bright orange yeah and I will never
forget that cheeto colored turd yeah it
shocked me it was you gonna have
something sensational like an orange
turd definitely something that's not
gonna leave your brain it was like a guy
directing traffic around a construction
site on the street you know you got to
wear the most like fluorescent orange
vest type situation what if it was like
he crapped a construction vest but what
if it wasn't a turd you ever thought
about that it was a tired man you sure
it wasn't just like a giant cheeto or
like a like a cheese puffs of some kind
you talked about he like was I don't eat
isn't he threw it in the toilet and it
expanded to turd size you tell him out a
cheeto the size of a baby's arm
it's a hot video Thanks yeah man I'll
never forget it so one of those two are
my first memory and they're equally
traumatic and I think that's the right
that's the that's the common denominator
here between our two stories right and I
don't have any other memories from
Georgia which is where I spent my first
three years it's funny because I would
have told you that I remembered when it
snowed that winter when I was three
years old but I don't actually remember
it I've just seen the pictures because I
do yeah I've seen the pictures of my mom
I've seen the pictures of me and my
brother with plastic bags tied over our
feet it's funny like him we were in we
were in Georgia prepared we're in South
Georgia and my mom's idea of like
keeping us safe in the snow is to put
slippery plastic bags around our feet
and send us out into the snow you don't
want your feet to get wet right you just
want to fall and break something I think
when you're a parent especially I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna I'm gonna project
this on your mom and assume that she
wasn't actually thinking this but
especially back in you know you'd put
your kids out the front door and you'd
say don't come back for a couple hours
matter of fact there's a couple of times
that I've even said that into my kids
now I'm like you know what I'm fed up
with these screens go outside and do not
come back in four and I'll say an hour
an hour's a long time but like 15
minutes later they they ring the
doorbell well if you send them out in
the snow and you don't put bags over
their socks and shoes then once those
socks get wet
[Music]
it's your big bird boy well I was three
I'm pretty sure she didn't believe and
it was snowing in Georgia which was very
unusual and I think that's why I thought
that I remembered it but I think it's
just a picture you think your mom put
plastic bags around in our own shoes no
it's like Reeboks that are back I don't
think so in style now
the things the additional things that I
remember is that there's awesome
sporadic things from my time and
Thousand Oaks California
what's your first member from there so
this will be your second memory I
honestly cannot put these in
chronological order I don't know because
I remember being taught how to ride a
bike and falling mm-hmm and and falling
a few houses down and then my pants
getting caught in the chain and not
being able to move and having to yell
for my dad to come after me and that's
probably I probably combined two
memories because there was when I was
learning to ride my bike and then me
riding my bike probably by myself and
that happening mm-hmm
I remember a giant sunflower what yeah
this is the only good this is the only
good memory that I that I have from back
it from really early you know what if
you really look at a giant sunflower
from up close I would argue that it's
actually pretty damn scary they're kind
of wicked when was last time you stare
down a sunflower it's like the black
part in the center is just is a lot
bigger than you feel like it should be
and it looks in the stuff that's coming
out of it the seed stuff it to me it's
like it's gross looking but how do you
remember it
well I think of it differently now that
you said that to me it's like staring at
a beautiful Sun that you can't not that
you can look at without looking away I
guarantee it was twice as big as your
head if it was a good one in my
recollection it was eight to nine feet
tall all right it was pretty tall for
its height but you weren't afraid of it
see that's the thing for me as a kid I
would have definitely been afraid of
that flower and I also remember the
first time I heard the f-word oh really
from Rochelle who's Rochelle Rochelle
was the coolest kid in our neighborhood
she was probably like five to six years
older than I was okay and I heard her
say it and then I went up and whispered
in her ear and I said
I just wanted to make sure I got it
right now I was like is a bad word and
she was like what did you say I said
what did she say she said she started
laughing and said yes it's a bad word
you can't say that even though I just
said whispered it twice into her ear so
she just said it in conversation yeah
yeah I mean this is like 1981 and you
got this girl just saying the f-word in
front of four-year-olds I don't remember
the first time I heard the f-word I
remember the when the Beastie Boys
cassette Licensed to Ill came out with
like fight for your right to party on it
and by this point my babysitter's name
why do you only remember things in the
context of being babysat because I was
babysat a lot I mean my mom was working
my mom was working man I know that but
like you also you did have a home and a
mom I think yeah and we do I I have
memories I'm saying but my mom didn't
use the f-word homey you would have
remembered if she my mom didn't say hey
let me open up the liner notes oh this
Beastie Boys album and let's I'm gonna
highlight every single naughty word so
you can learn it that's what Joe the
older boy did we would he would he would
literally point to every single nasty
word and he would also tell me about the
female anatomy oh you need to know but
like in detail you know there's like
just like certain things you can say in
general about down there and then you
can also go like really really
anatomical right like imagine the most
anatomical conversation and I guess I
was I don't know you know I might have
been 10 oh so if you passed you're not
so but I mean you fast-forward all the
way to 10
well I mean if we're talking about like
pretty sporadic not what's my first
memory of being taught something illicit
is now what we're talking about okay
my first illicit memory is then and you
know what a few days later Joe's younger
brother got sick and he was
laying on the floor the same floor that
we laid on when we were like trying to
hide the Beastie Boys liner notes and he
started to vomit in the kid the kids
started to vomit and instead of rolling
over on his side or standing up or
running to the bathroom he rolled over
on his back and he was projectile
vomiting straight up in the air and you
can die from that you can easily choke
like a fountain
like a vomit fountain yeah and it's so I
think somebody came and pushed him over
it's like did a log roll it's like you
just can't yeah you just can't let a kid
that sideways man before telling I told
you the story about my babysitter trying
to dare me to pull the wart off her
finger oh gosh you have so many you're
like she was she I mean rude up man god
rest her dead soul but we would sit in
the swing and wait for my mom to come to
show up and I would always be the last
one to get picked up because my mom
worked late she was a hard-working woman
and I was so anxious I had this
separation anxiety and I saw I was
afraid that my mom wasn't gonna pick me
up and so while you're waiting you can
try to get a wart on woman we would sit
in the swing and she would she'd look up
and she say we look she looked down the
street is a long long driveway she
looked down the driveway and she said oh
there she don't come that was her joke
there she don't come and it was like I
could tell by the look in her face as I
oh [ __ ] my mom's coming and then then I
thought let's just screwing oh you stop
for a second well I'm just gonna pile it
all on and then you can untie lit so
then in that same scene she would say in
order to occupy my time while I was
waiting for my mom and she was taunting
me she would say see if you can pull off
this ward and I wit was a big wart it
was like it was the size of an infant's
pinkie she was old and it was on the
side of her index finger like between
the second and final knuckle there was a
wart on the side and I would grab this
wart and pull and I actually I was
sometimes I would dig my fingernails
underneath it and I and that would make
me happy because I knew that I was
hurting her a little bit but she would
just grow
would just grit her teeth and she would
not she wouldn't she it was like it was
like a game of mercy I think she might
actually pull it off she either wanted
that thing I was gonna get this but she
didn't want to admit that I was yanking
her heart on that board okay listen
listen I remember all that y'all these
are my memories linked anatomically
detailed this woman was a witch do you
remember what she looked like no she
picked me up one that she had this
why are we talking this woman she had a
long Cadillac but it was two doors but
the doors were as long as what would
normally cross like a stretch limos
worth a three doors it was the longest
door a kid couldn't open the door a
teacher had to come when she pulled up
open the door for me and let me get in
the backseat and then she had the window
rolled down I remember I put my hand out
the window one day and I was sitting
behind her as she was driving and she's
leaving Buies Creek Elementary School
and she starts rolling up the window and
I tried to take my hand out but the
window rolled up so quickly that my hand
got stuck and I was like oh my my hands
in the window my hands stuck and she
rolled it down a little bit and as I was
about to pull it out she rolled it up
again she she kept my hand in the window
dude and just just to screw with me
she was demented hold on but what but
why do you have you don't have fond
memories of her you have you have
horrific memories of her I don't
understand
I was not redder I loved redder I still
loved redder she's still alive and she's
a beautiful 4 foot 10 inch woman and I'm
not I'm not exaggerating but that's how
tall she with no warts on her hand
no warts beautiful small hands real hair
though because when actually had the
hair of a giant when I think about those
days again my first memory was traumatic
but like when I think about I bottled
all that [ __ ] up to men I never once
told my mom about it yeah that's a
problem yeah like four five six
I remember the
was a guy in our neighborhood who had a
pitbull who would pull him at very high
speeds while he was on a skateboard
barefooted what that's Cali
that's Cali yeah but that's the kind of
I mean I've got good memory wart yeah I
remembers when the Santa Ana winds would
come and my brother and I would put on
giant jackets and go and hold them open
and lean completely into the wind so it
would hold us up like I'm not saying I
didn't have bad memories but there were
no women with warts that were trying to
get me to pull him off and there was no
evil woman trying to get my hands stuck
in the window or getting my hand stuck
in the the the swing I mean do you
remember anything good nobody made me
get my hand caught in the swing okay do
you have any other two things that
happen were both the same woman so at
least they were the same woman I mean if
those are two different women that would
suck I did have another babysitter who
would say go outside she make me go
outside for the hour that she was
watching the bold and the beautiful or
whatever soap opera she was into and I
hated it because it was just like I
would sit on the steps waiting for her
show to be over so I could go back
inside
that's not babysitting yeah it's
horrible and you didn't think I I think
I need to tell my mom I don't I think I
did complain about that woman and then I
stopped we stopped I stopped going here
good for you
stop going there how do we get on this
so yeah I mean clearly the trunk I I
have good memories too I have good
memories from my childhood name one
I remember the wart didn't come off yeah
I don't I don't I I could probably come
up with some good memories but what's
the fun in that
well okay kind of getting back to what
you talked about with Lando yes
in this same article from psych central
it's pretty interesting so okay research
is showing that infants do not have the
sophisticated neural architect
needed to form and hold on to more
complex forms of memory okay for their
experiment the researchers recorded 83
children at the age of three while their
mothers or father's asked them about
events that they had experienced in
recent months oh gosh is a trip to the
zoo or a birthday party
Bauer explained that parents were asked
to speak as they normally would to their
children prompting them with questions
such as remember when we went to
chuck-e-cheeses for your birthday party
you had pizza didn't you the child might
then recount details of the birthday
party or divert the conversation to
another event such as a visit to the zoo
the researchers noted that some mothers
might keep asking about pizza while
other mothers would ask about the trip
to the zoo parents who followed a
child's lead in these conversations
tended to elicit richer memories from
their three-year-olds according to Bauer
this approach also related to the
children having a better memory of the
event at a later age okay and then and
in this study because I read about this
two years later they went back and asked
them about those same memories to see
what was retained and what was it yeah
cuz it says while the children between
the ages of five and seven could recall
63 to 72 percent of the events the
children who were eight and nine years
old remembered only about 35 percent of
the events the researchers reported so
if you've got kids yes this is what I'm
getting at first of all I'm just gonna
go there's an opportunity here the
youngest child between the two of us is
nine right so you've already missed the
window well here's what I should have
been doing this at five and seven and so
only if you've got kids who are younger
than seven years old listen up because I
think we've got a technique for yeah
this is exactly what I what occurred to
me when I just happen to be talking to
Lando about this I was like dude and I
didn't know about the seven and nine but
I was like okay you're nine years old
you're so much closer to all of these
memories then I am to my memories or
even the older kids are to theirs I mean
I can help you remember more details we
can sit here we can talk about the
details of that house in Encino riding a
scooter all the way around it getting in
that hammock he started to remember
stuff about the rabbit and like all the
stuff in that kid's house when we
go feed the rabbit I was like you know
what now that's your first memory it
doesn't involve a wart
it doesn't involve bleeding and this is
a gift that parents or mentors or uncool
uncle's or aunts can give short
babysitters to your short babysitters
you can give to your your your progeny
here you can help them you can establish
rich or first memories I mean it's you
know there's the gift of like our
parents gave us a gift of all the
pictures that we have you know those
platt the plastic wrapped around your
your legs your feet you don't really
remember that but you almost could have
and if if you would have talked about it
at age 7 and then kept talking about it
you went we've talked about how the act
of remembering creates the memory again
and makes it more memorable well it
rewrites it as well rewrites it so this
is another way T thing that you might
interpret is pressure that's what I
would do as a parent to say you can
instill but your kid I think the
technique well yeah I think you're
taking a little too far but this is
sensational I know what I'm saying is
that you've got to use this technique
though when you and I think it sounds
like you did this whether it was
intentional or not it was just 2 years
too late
when lando started talking about his
memory you when they bring up something
like the rabbit will follow the rabbit
like literally follow the rabbit and ask
them questions about the rabbit idli
like let them lead it and they'll kind
of be they'll be recalling it and
solidifying it a rich memory that then
when they're 41 and 42 years old and
they're talking about the good old days
they'll have they'll have less traumatic
things to talk about and we had well and
they and I think the video component is
a big one because I don't mm-hmm I think
that the first video of me that's
available is definitely not before
middle school I mean we don't Wow nobody
was taking any video of us my my my
parents got a video camera when I was
already in high school so we didn't have
a family video camera
um yeah it was just like school projects
the first video footage that I have of
me is my aunt TC she was she was she was
big into these camcorders and she would
always bring that to Christmas and she
would like say she'd set up the tripod
and she'd have it in the corner of the
room and then she'd come around and film
everybody so every Christmas starting
like yeah when I was in like you know
when you start getting those big
shoulder mount cameras I don't know what
year that would be I would have footage
of Christmas at Nana and Papa's house
and I would take that camera and not
tell her and I would film stuff at Nana
Papa's house I'd film like little videos
and I filmed this time-travel of movie
that involved flushing the toilet and
this filming that was like zooming in on
the water and they're like voicing that
over as like a time travel portal and
then I think that was pretty much the
only scene I remember that okay you
think you can get hold of this footage
mm-hmm but I bet she still has all of it
but it's just like all of us opening
presents you mean you mean me and
filming a toilet well I think that was
pretty much it
don't you think that you should like
Digita if she has footage of you as a
kid like I think that you should get
that digitized you should talk to her
about this yeah those VHS tapes are not
gonna hold up forever it's already
degraded quite a bit probably I mean
that's it I mean it was definitely grade
school it wasn't it was a middle school
I might well I don't know if I told you
this but sixth grade maybe because you
know I got that 360 degree camera right
and so one of the things I started doing
on like our vacations is it every city
that we went to when we were in Scotland
in England you know I would take a
number of these pictures and I put them
up I think I talked about it and I
posted it but now I can put on my oculus
and I go to that website well I've got
my oculus on and I can enter into those
photos and see and there's 360 video
which with the camera that I got is not
very high
but the photos are great because I could
be like oh I remember when we were on
that hike and we stopped and we took
that picture in there's lock there
Shepherd and there's my nephews and
nieces and because sometime in the
future it's just gonna be it's gonna be
much easier than putting on an oculus to
just explore that photo and we'll have
some of the early well that's exactly
what I'm talking about so and I still
have it I kind of regret that I haven't
done this yet but the good news is my
kids rooms haven't changed substantially
in the past couple of years since we've
moved into this house but you you know
you're like what was it like in my room
as a kid so what I'm gonna do is go in
there and just like you know stand in
the middle of room hold the thing up and
take a 360 photo or let them do it so
it's not dad holding it and let that and
then you've got this photo that forever
like for the rest of their lives they
can be like what was it like in my room
when I was 11 years old oh I can I can
go there right now
you know and there's the book that I was
reading and oh yeah I think that there's
my Garfield phone it's like that's
something that I would love to be able
to have you know I would love to be able
to do that personally right but you know
it's like a society side benefit of this
too you know for insurance purposes like
if your house burns down I know I'm a
downer today when your house burns down
you can if you've uploaded those to the
cloud then you can just send her to the
insurance company and say I want all of
this back well that's actually that was
enough that was actually my first idea
when I got this camera I was like I need
to take pictures of every room in the
house so that I can actually show the
insurance company in case of a fire but
then I was like oh but this also creates
like a literal memory palace that my
kids can go into right with the with
these uh with an oculus so what are we
concluding here your first memories you
you might have made them up
but if you have influence over a
seven-year-old there at the perfect age
to just to cultivate out what Reza time
a ver do
memory garden of first memories that's
the influence you can have over over the
next generation you can thank us for it
and you know what when you're talking
about seven year I'll say hey you know
what you should listen to your biscuits
that's where I learned this from you
might be into it um it's our target
audience seven year olds and I and you
know I can just I can make a
recommendation here based on the camera
that I have okay is this your is this
your official rec you know that my
official rec okay it's got three hundred
and forty-eight ratings on Amazon four
stars so I guess it's been fine for me
like I said the yeah it looks like a USB
Drive with the lens on the end of it
this is the did that small I don't know
if is that Rico how do you are I CoH
Rica Veda Ricoh theta SC 360 video and
still camera comes in four colors I have
the white one Jesse just got this for me
at some point how much is it it is a
white ones a hundred and eighty bucks
well what's the cheapest color no for a
360 camera are the white one the rest
the rest of them are two hundred
everything else is two hundred but the
white one is cheaper okay because it
shows dirt and again like I said at
least the last time that I now that
camera that we used on the going back to
buoys cream for the documentary jagged
you remember you remember what kind of
camera that was at 360 camera that we
use we crossed the river because that
one was much more pricey that was more
of a video camera first this this feels
more like flip phone is it 4k though no
I mean well it's uh let's see what it
says here I don't know what the video
resolution is it's like I said this is
basically for pictures like the pictures
are adequate to like capture a memory if
you just want to you know and you don't
have to have it you can actually then
like upload them to a website and go
into it and look at it or whatever but
oh it was a GoPro it was the new three
360 GoPro which is
that thing for video is awesome but you
don't have to good because I'm sommore
eyes you can't just like get a phone
that has backward and forward facing
lenses just hold that thing up and
there's a program where you can just
push a button well there probably is
that probably is a thing that is
probably not quite as good as this
though yeah that is like pretty seamless
you know what if you don't want to take
Rhett wreck just wait a little bit and
your phone will probably start doing it
well I just think in the distant future
everybody is gonna have like some sort
of head where even if it's in your
glasses and it's gonna be like little
antenna goes up and it's now you've got
the 360 you know I want to remember this
moment I want remember everything about
this and I want to be able to enter into
the physical space you want the sights
and the sounds of this situation and
just be able to do that yeah we should
invent that in the meantime you can call
it Google glasses
all right well partner with Google okay
we're gonna provide the glasses we're
gonna provide the antenna with a camera
on the end of it actually we're not
gonna provide that at all we're gonna
provide the idea you just heard it
Google glasses if you like the idea of
us having a antenna installed on your
Google glasses you like hit us up and
we'll tell you all about it it's an
antenna with a camera on it all right if
you want to hit us up in general hashtag
ear biscuits let us know join the
conversation what's your very first
memory I think this is something good
icebreaker conversation for your family
friends loved ones are conversations on
a plane what what have you we're here
for you and we'll be back next week like
I said we'll still be talking about the
last year's in some capacity yeah thanks
for listening thanks for sharing this
episode with a friend who you want to
remember
or you want them to remember their first
memory tell them about our show we are
we are in your debt
don't forget remember to tell them about
our show will speak at you next week to
watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]